à 11 ans au collège la récré ça sert
plutôt à se défouler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que bon
il s'appelle
je me balade un peu je drague un peu de
filles comme ça je fais n'importe quoi
de temps en temps je me bagarre c'est un
peu la galère avec mes amis je me relaxe
je reste dans les toilettes et je
discute avec des copains
c'est moins agité on peut sortir cela
s'appelle un intercours et les jeux eux
sont un petit peu plus sérieux
ou sinon on se retrouve au café on
laisse pas toujours les récréations quoi
des fois on a cours on a deux heures de
cours même si elle a récréation il me
laisse pas y aller on va viser le son ou
non c'est plus pareil on est on est plus
grand il y a c'est vraiment on s'amuse
plus quand on est plus petit quoi